get a frying pan smoking-hot essential  for quick pan frying  I deliver oil  then seasoned scallops with salt and  pepper starting at the top put clockwise  into the pan so you know which one to  turn first  [Applause]  [Music]  scallops have firm white sweet flesh and  cook in minutes  [Applause]  [Music]  next salad lamb's lettuce matchsticks  with apple  seasoning  lemon zest and juice  [Applause]  at Olive Oyl then toss  [Applause]  [Music]  turn the scallops when golden don't  clockwise around the pan  [Applause]  then squeeze in lemon juice and give the  pan a shake finish with lemon zest  ready in under ten minutes my first  pan-fried dish scallops with crunchy  apple salad